my name is Jamie price I was the visual
effects supervisor on downsizing and I'm
going to take you through a bit of the
history of the miniaturization of people
in movies one of the first primary uses
of visual effects to shrink people was
in the movie the Bride of Frankenstein
in 1935 in order to blend the big people
in the small people together two pieces
of footage had to be shot first there
was a background plate featuring dr.
Pretorius in his lab and then there were
additional shots made of the people that
would be shrunk down and placed into the
jars measurements were taken on set and
then those measurements were scaled up
and the people who were meant to be
small were photographed from a much
larger distance and therefore they
looked smaller in the frame and early on
in the 30s before the advent of blue
screen technology there weren't that
many options for compositing images like
this together
it was created using composites done by
the Williams process which was a process
where people were shot against black and
the brightness could be then used to
create an outline of the character what
we call a math and then those characters
were composited into the live-action
background
19:40 dr. Cyclops was being done and
that was in color and the Williams
process wasn't really suitable for color
and so a lot of the solutions in dr.
cyclops were to use rear projection
the background projection image was big
the people in the foreground appeared
small and in the final shot you saw the
mix of the scales another thing that's
really interesting about dr. Cyclops is
some of the creativity that they used to
have the interaction between the big
people and small people you see a
mechanical oversized hand that an actor
is grasped by and the camera is lined up
with that oversized hand in the rear
projection screen to create the illusion
of the continuous body of dr. Cyclops
dr. Cyclops also introduces the idea of
a cat threatening some small people and
it's interesting to note in this
sequence the difference in the look of
the shots between when they're
photographing the small people on
oversized sets and when they're
photographing the cat against a real set
what's at play here is the idea of depth
of field and depth of field is the
amount of frame that's in focus and so
if you look at the coverage of this
scene you'll see that when photographing
the cat the camera is closed and the
background is very blurry but when
photographing the people the camera is
farther away but it results in the two
halves of the scene have a kind of
fundamentally different look and it may
not be something that you notice at
first right away but there's something
subtle that's giving away that the two
sides of the scene were shot in
different ways 1957 The Incredible
Shrinking man now the depth of field is
more controlled but what's interesting
about this scene also involving a cap
the focus is deeper and it's a better
match to the shots that are showing
grant Williams and so you begin to feel
that the scene is becoming more of a
whole
19:59 Darby O'Gill and the little people
what they did was make extensive use of
force perspective force perspective is
creating the illusion of something being
small by placing it far away from the
camera and photographing it at the same
time as something close so that when the
two subjects share the frame at the same
time one looks much smaller than the
other this required a lot of light the
story is that they got every light in
Hollywood and used them to photograph
these scenes they placed one actor on a
set piece that was scaled up and
artfully blended so that when the camera
was lined up just perfectly it looked
like it was part of the foreground set
another interesting and old technique
that was used was something called the
shift in shot and the shift in shot
involves using a mirror where a portion
of the reflective coating is scratched
away feeling just clear glass when you
shoot the mirror you look through a
portion of it and you look at a
reflection in the other portion and by
placing the object either through the
clear of glass or in the reflection much
farther away you create the illusion of
two images being blended together this
was a technique that had was used in the
30s as early as films like metropolis it
wasn't really until the advent of
digital technology that new technique
started to be utilized
look in 1991 use some of the similar
techniques composites and blue-screen in
order to create a miniature look of
Tinker Bell Tinker Bell was also
combined with photographic elements for
her wings that were actual miniatures
and had the proper small scale that were
photographed separately and then
composited with her 1995 brought Indian
in the cupboard they really made an
effort to honor the optical principles
of photography when photographing
something small and that means that they
really studied the depth of field and
the optical properties of the lenses
when you look at some of the shots you
see the backgrounds are quite out of
focus and that's because they're really
going for this look to make the
foreground character look small another
technique that was used is motion
control motion control is a system where
a robotic camera has moved that matches
its own movement the same way every
single time and that way multiple
elements can be shot and combined and
they won't appear to be moving against
each other because the camera has made
the exact same move every time thanks to
the electronics and the robotics and the
Gears Lord of the Rings 2003 the
culmination of all of the techniques
that we've been talking about forced
perspective compositing digital
technology were all being utilized to
create the mix of scales in this movie
one interesting advance in Lord of the
Rings was the use of motion control to
actually create force perspective with a
moving camera in the early days if the
camera was not in exactly the right
place the gag would be given away and
the shot wouldn't work anymore this was
accomplished by placing one actor at a
certain distance from the camera another
actor at a farther distance from the
camera and then as the camera moved the
actor in the distance would also move so
that they appeared to be constantly the
same distance
ant-man 2015 in order to achieve the
realism level in ant-man special sets
were built and photographed with a still
camera and a library was created of
images for each of these small-scale
sets that allowed the filmmakers to then
recreate those sets digitally and
compose whatever shot they wanted from
whatever angle they wanted and with
whatever depth of field that they wanted
that brings us to downsize in 2017
Alexander PEYA didn't move the camera
very much and he didn't cut very often
which meant that the shots were subject
to a very very high level of scrutiny
all of our measurements had to be
extremely precise or the audience would
tell over the course of the shot that
the perspective wasn't quite right or
the lighting wasn't quite right so we
really were incredibly meticulous with
our notes with duplicating our
environments one of the techniques that
we decided not to use was the idea of
oversized props and sets we felt in
looking back at the earlier work as good
as it was there was always something
about the detail level that gave it away
however one of the things that we knew
we needed was the actual interaction for
the actor and the lighting interaction
of being in a set we use one of the
oldest techniques in motion pictures and
that's rotoscoping rotoscoping is where
the outline of a character is traced
frame by frame so that that character
can then be taken out of whatever the
background they're in and placed into
another one we actually did build
oversized sets but we knew we were never
going to use those sets in the final
image they were just there for the actor
to have something to work with and for
the cinematographer to be able to light
one of the things that changes when
you're photographing something big or
small is the relationship of the size of
the subject to the size of the light so
as the subject gets smaller the light
relative to them gets bigger and that
meant we had to have very large light
sources then the actor was rotoscoped
out and then composited into the
background and that's what appears in
the final movie I think what's most
exciting about the trajectory the visual
effects technology has taken is how much
freedom filmmakers have now there are a
lot fewer limitations being placed on
filmmakers because of Technology
because of visual effects and that
allows their imagination to really take
flight Wow
that is wild isn't it it's just wild